hey guys I'm no master chef but I'm in a
rush in my daily life so I need quick
healthy easy meal options to make during
the day so let's get some ingredients I
got my new school shopping list right
here no more pen and paper
[Music]
I'm no Gordon Ramsay when it comes to
being in the kitchen but I do know a
thing or two about nutrition these are
five quick easy and nutritious meals
that you can make at home when you're on
the go
enter chef dr. Mac let's start with my
favorite dish I like to call this bad
boy the underdog because most people
think sardines ill know first of all
sardines are delicious second of all
they're an excellent source of omega-3
fatty acids that's the stuff that you
need to develop a healthy brain healthy
eyes we've seen a lot of studies show
that people who consume fish on a
regular basis not only are smarter but
they also sleep better below that you
have guacamole that has hosaka kados in
it it has tomatoes as onions rich in
vegetables all on top of this crisp
bread which has sunflower seeds flax
seeds sesame seeds it's rich in whole
grains has 3 grams of fiber 3 grams of
protein this is a killer nutritious
snack that you can really eat on the go
don't mind the sardine
[Music]
up next we have something that I munched
on all the time in college the dorm room
special it's really simple it's not
elegant but it really does the trick
oven roasted turkey breast followed by
my favorite cheese Munster cheese and
then you have two slices of cucumbers a
lot of nutrition packed into this little
bad boy here you have proteins from the
cheese and the turkey and then you have
antioxidants and polyphenols from the
cucumbers cucumbers contain lignans and
they have a strong history of research
in connection with reduced risk of
cardiovascular disease as well as some
cancers either and who doesn't like
themselves a little extra crunch
[Music]
the antioxidant one-two punch that's
right
the reason why I call this antioxidant
one-two punch is because green apples my
favorite kind of apples
yes Granny Smith have a ton of
antioxidants as well as polyphenols so
the saying an apple a day keeps your
doctor ways partially true because they
do have a host of health benefits they
also are rich in fiber which keeps you
fuller longer it also helps with sugar
management then you have on the side as
a little dipping portion of cottage
cheese rich in protein calcium b12 all
essential nutrients to keep your body
going then you finally top it off with a
little bit of extra flavor from cinnamon
which is zero calories that's right
zero calories and cinnamon also loaded
in antioxidants sets of two in the
one-two punch cinnamon has shown promise
in preventing issues with your heart
it's also shown to help better manage
sugar within your body whether you're
diabetic or not diabetic antioxidant
one-two punch tastes great and low
calorie
[Music]
the bear please sir
yep I named this after my puppy bear and
what this is is just basic Greek yogurt
mixed with some multigrain gluten-free
granola I added a couple of walnuts for
myself because I love walnuts and then
finish off with a little drizzle of
honey Greek yogurt rich in protein and a
great source of probiotics
yeah probiotics is all that bacteria
that lives with inside your gut that
helps you to have healthy digestion
helps you to go to the bathroom more
regularly
normal stools we've seen a lot of
benefits from people eating yogurt the
multigrain granola is great because the
one that I buy has actually nine
different seeds and nuts in it you're
getting a lot of fiber and getting a lot
of nutrients packed in and that crunch
is unbelievable I think that yogurt on
its own especially plain yogurt and
granola this is kind of tasteless so
what I do is I take my favorite I guess
food topping if you call it and I
drizzle a little bit of honey on the top
give it a ton of flavor because honey is
rich in sugar but honey is also rich in
polyphenols antioxidants and we've seen
some promising studies talking about the
favorable effect on cholesterol so this
is a meal that I love and bear loves
[Music]
last and least it may not be the most
adult one of these five but it's
certainly a favorite of mine childhood
peanut butter and jelly peanut butter
really gets a bad rap because it's high
in fat it has some saturated fats and in
small amounts saturated fats are not bad
for you and it's rich in unsaturated
fats which are also good for you peanut
butter is also a great way for people
who are vegetarian or vegan to get their
protein up when selecting the bread for
your PB&J make sure it's one that has
whole grain and whole wheat in the first
two ingredients to make sure it's the
healthiest type of bread that you can
get rich in fiber if you're gonna choose
a jam make sure it's a high-quality jam
not just jam that's packed with a ton of
sugar
make sure it's made with real fruit
clearly you don't need to put in a lot
of effort to make really quick and
nutritious foods I mean most of these
here have three or four ingredients at
most and maybe they took me five minutes
to make as always guys stay happy and
healthy look I am no Bobby Flay look I
am no Gordon Ramsay when it comes to
cooking but I do know a little thing
about nutrition a little thing let's
break down each one how does it have
that become anything if you like this
nutrition video please give it a like
and a share if you want to see what I
eat in a day click here
[Music]